all right we're continuing to hear from
people via discord
at davidpakman.com
discord let's go uh next
to uh why don't we go oh i don't know
there's just so many interesting
locations
let's go to sean from san antonio texas
next
hello can you hear me yes i can hey
uh david uh yeah just got into you here
about a year ago
um but i did have a question is that i
just
yesterday i have a roommate here that
we're both on kind of
different political ends of the spectrum
okay and
i'm starting to go and uh kind of get
some like whispers of different
you know farther right kind of q stuff
and i kind of had to go and actually sit
down with her and kind of have like a
discussion of like hey like so what's
going on and try to
meet in the middle if that makes sense i
don't know how you meet in the middle
with q
stuff but it sounds like you were kind
of trying to stage an intervention of
sorts which is good
yeah yeah i'm just trying to understand
it more
and what i kind of ran into as the
circumstance
uh yesterday was kind of the situation
where
um i was kind of wanting to at least
have the the conversation because it
kind of got to the point of
uh she was so emotional that she was
like crying kind of like
why is this happening and kind of having
like anger and disgust of
what's happening in the country but wait
a second we need to clarify that because
if you're talking about a cue
was she crying because they stole it
from trump or was she crying because
there were violent riots incited by
trump
oh well i mean the the specific thing
that she brought up was that
um the media is going and saying that
antifa
are they oh no wait what was is that
antifa was the one that actually went
and stormed the capital okay okay
and and i kind of just let that one go
because i'm not gonna
i i'm having to live with this person
yeah completely delusional but you can't
do anything about it
yeah and so but but with that um
circumstance the
the situation i ran into was that they
um wouldn't want to engage and i
understand that we're not going to be
able to kind of meet in the middle as
we were talking but yeah um what would
you say
in going and um deprogramming
the the conversation to get people to
start understanding that like
you know that this is what happens in
life like i i had to go and live with
a kind of a crazy four years the last
four years and you know
you didn't have your side win and that's
kind of what it is
and we kind of need to make it past that
but i i wish i could
suggestions unfortunately the
the cue stuff you know some of these
people are so far gone
that i mean listen think back to the jim
jones
cult were you gonna be able to just pull
someone aside and say hey you know this
is pretty wacky you should quit
obviously that's not going to work
there's a level of radicalization
and and uh a true belief as they see it
i don't know what i really do not know
when someone is
in that deep i feel like you almost have
to say
this person is lost and maybe we'll get
lucky and something will happen by
chance to change their mind
but let's focus on fixing education
culture and media literacy
to prevent someone from even being
susceptible to this in the first place
because i don't know how you
de-radicalize someone that just
someone like your roommate i don't know
yeah yeah well
it's definitely a work work in progress
or at least trying to go and keep
some civility yeah with that in the
switch to change is that
um what would you have as guidance
towards going
and kind of enacting or being more a
part of that change
if that makes sense because i i'm now
with kind of everything that's been
going on
been getting more kind of into it but
i'm still kind of i guess
looking for the next right steps to go
and start pushing towards
agendas that are a little more in the
positive for people
there's no shortage of ways to get
involved if you want to get involved
with education
i mean it depends how local you want to
go but you i mean there's so many ways
to affect positive change in our
communities
get involved in local races when there's
a candidate that you believe in and that
you think is going to make the changes
that you you want to see
if you think that part of the problem we
have is the electoral vote get involved
in pushing the national popular vote
interstate compact if you want to focus
on
uh get no longer filling up
prisons with non-violent drug offenders
you can get involved with
drug policy i mean there's you have to
there's so much you just have to figure
out first
where you can't focus on everything
figure out what you what is most
important to you
and then figure out how to get involved
in that specifically
got it well i appreciate it david you
have a great rest of your day
my pleasure you as well uh great that so
many people want to get involved
that's uh that's that's the start for
sure
let's go next to fran from philly fran
from philly you're on the air hello
yes you're on there okay yeah um big
canada show i've been watching for too
much now
up until uh
okay so my friend in order for me to
hear you
you're gonna have to figure out if
there's a piece of paper or a banana or
a shirt sleeve rubbing up against your
microphone or what it is
because every time you talk it we just
can't hear you
can you hear me now yeah that's much
better okay okay
so i just wanted to get i just wanted to
get into this thing i saw on twitter
okay so this guy named eric hernandez he
has a
he has a long twitter thread going on
and he's basically
saying that members of congress are
colluding no he's basically saying that
members of congress colluded with um the
terrorists
for example um ayanna presley said that
her panic buttons
were were removed for were removed from
her office
in clyburn also at his unmarked office
was alluded but marked office um remain
untouched right so let me explain that
second thing so people know uh
congressman clyburn says he believes
that there was some inside job aspect to
what took place because he has two
offices he has his office that is his
office as as congressman with his name
on it
and then he has an unmarked office where
i believe he's
the majority whip where he works as
majority whip and that
only insiders would know about the
unmarked office and the location
otherwise they would just go to the one
with his name on it i've i've seen that
i don't know the truth of it i want to
be clear that a lot of this stuff
is being asserted and if if these things
are true
there have to be answers i don't know
and i want to be careful about asserting
things that i don't yet know more about
but
you're right these these allegations are
being made
yeah so how do we move on from this
if um these things being true
how do we um come together with the
republicans
i mean listen i i hate to say this but
i don't know that there's any coming
together with the current republicans
i it's it's terrible just to have to say
it that way
but how is this republican party
that it either is trumpist or stood
aside
while trump destroyed the country
because they decided it was best for
them
how do you work with them i don't i
don't know i don't know that it's
possible sadly i wish i had something
more optimistic to say
thank you so much my pleasure friend
thank you
a depressing call uh but an important
call
certainly one of our sponsors is hydrant
which is a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration
and they're giving you 25 off your first
order it's made with four key
electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my
daily routine for a while now keeping
myself hydrated puts me
in a better mood the body needs
hydration for basic energy and focus and
hydrant is the perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a b
c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
percent off your first order when you go
to drink hydrant dot com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video